The Joe Rogan Experience it's like we
have these ideas about what these things
are that's based on a [__] version
of them including the Yellowstone
version when we were in Yellowstone you
could hang out 10 feet from an elk
they're just right there right they
don't worry about people at all they're
hanging out in the visitor center
they're laying down in front of
everybody that was probably not
September then because they weren't
running no they weren't running no no it
was the summertime but it was it was
still it was totally alien Behavior
right like completely domesticated yeah
and just imagine what it was like when
they reintroduced wolves into that area
oh God bloodbath because this is this is
the animal that you're dealing you're
forcing an animal to be reintegrated
with the most ferocious death right so
you think there's too many of them you
think it's imbalanced you think they
shouldn't have killed off the Wolves
okay well now what now you're just gonna
all these cute elk that have been
hanging out the visitor center are just
gonna get butchered yeah and they don't
know what the [__] a wolf is right
they've had generation after generation
after generation no Wolves yeah they're
like no wolves great we're just out here
hanging out no the occasional mountain
lion whatever whatever but an occasional
Mountain line is nothing like a pack of
wolves no
now black wolves makes a whole lot more
wolves and they all stay together and
they hunt together they got a process
for killing they got it down they got it
down you know you got some sort of
telepathy or something you've seen where
they communicate where one wolf will
tire out the next wolf will fill in yeah
like a little Relay Team yeah wearing
out one animal yeah you know the prey
animal and it's uh yeah they're just
they'll wipe stuff out just like the
brown bear in those you know those seven
brown bear they're just they're born to
kill they don't know when to stop you
know so it's not I saw somebody said on
my page I said well wouldn't they kill
and just sit come back and just eat eat
off that for later and you know live off
that one kill I'm like what what are you
talking about if they go on Rampages
sometimes you you flip that switch on
yeah they're killing everything yeah
they're not like Native Americans they
only want to like kill what they're
using every piece of the sandwich yeah
no they're not like that they don't have
any they don't have any idea of
conservationism
their idea is to just kill everything
that's in front of them and there was a
uh what was it recently there was a
crazy one where this pack of wolves
killed like an enormous number of elk it
was like 18 elk something crazy yeah
just went on a ramp yeah just I don't
know what happened or how they they got
so many of them but it happens with
livestock all the time yeah well can you
see if we can find those like Surplus
killing me I believe it was in Wyoming
if I remember correctly
but they were shocked they were like
Jesus they just killed them yeah they
didn't even they weren't even eating
them right they just went on a rampage
they weren't hungry
that I mean that's what they're born to
do yeah wolf pack Slaughters 19 elk in
rare Surplus killing so this is in 2016.
it's not rare though I mean so even even
that word rare yeah well who's saying
rare well I think it's rare to get that
many I wonder I wonder what the
circumstances were where they could kill
that many yeah there's there's a photo
of all the elk lined up that was right
above it's horrible yeah look at that
that's crazy yeah I just I'm not
convinced that it's rare I think it's
rare that we find out about it how many
wolves did that that's what I want to
know I don't know I want to know how
many wolves if there was 19 what you got
50 wolves up there you got 100 wolves
like are there [__] super Pacs up
there that we don't know about I don't I
they have a good accounting of how many
wolves are up there oh it says nine
wolves nine oh yeah I was gonna say I
don't think it would take that many to
do that that's incredible because those
are all see it's 17 calves so that's
that's kind of the point with that
muskox videos those were calves they
don't they can't run into adults yeah 17
calves and two adults wow I mean they
they can't run like a full-grown what
musk ox or elk or anything else so
they're they're pretty much just right
for the picking that's bear even black
bear will follow elk around when they
know it's calving season right when the
calf is born they'll kill it Luke said
Lund also described the kill to CNN as
sport killing although the consensus
among biologists and Wildlife officials
is that wolves do not hunt for sport but
sometimes kill more than they can eat at
one point especially in winter when
frigid temperatures preserve the killed
prey for later consumption you know what
I bet though
I bet they can't help themselves when
they see calves no I bet it's like the
switch is on yeah it's like a kitten
with a ball of yarn roll a ball yarn
from a kid
if they see babies like baby moose baby
deer baby elk like I'm taking the time
to kill you don't get a chance they're
babies for a short amount of time you
got to get them now somebody else said
that too that they didn't know animals
killed just for the fun of it I'm like
you ever seen a house cat bro house cats
kill literally billions of animals a
year yeah or feral cats really that's
right mostly outdoor I mean it's all
it's Mo I bet a lot of the killing is
done by actual feral cats but a lot of
it's done by people's pets